When is a "co-ed shower scene" not just a
"co-ed shower scene"?
"Starship Troopers" is way more than just
casual nudity, fascist formalwear, and giant
alien bugs.
This sci-fi satire was lightyears ahead of
its time.
"Starship Troopers" goes to work right away,
shaping its viewers' brains into the ideal
mindset for a soldier.
The opening scenes feature commercials from
a 23rd-century regime known as the United
Citizen Federation.
The clips vary from information on the savagery
of the arachnid enemy to positive outcomes
for enlisting in the military.
The not-so-subtle brainwashing leaves you
confused about your feelings towards Starship
Troopers, and that's helped this cult classic
shine brighter over the years.
The military propaganda videos are truly a
unique form of satire, one that becomes more
transparent with each viewing.
Director Paul Verhoeven claimed to have only
read a couple chapters of the source material
— Robert Heinlein's 1959 novel — before
retiring it to the dust bin.
In an interview with Empire, he explained:
"It's a very right-wing book.
And with the movie we tried, and I think at
least partially succeeded, in commenting on
that at the same time…All the way through
we were fighting with the fascism, the ultra-militarism."
Rather than glorify the book's fascist elements,
Verhoeven pulled us into the muck with an
awareness of something being terribly wrong
with this totalitarian society and its military
obsession.
Its satirical attributes are constructed so
well that it's easy to miss the film's intentions
as it presents a developed form of fascism
on a cosmic scale.
These details even sailed right over the heads
of many critics who accused Verhoeven of being
a neo-Nazi himself.
They completely misunderstood his achievement
in taking fascist rhetoric and dressing it
up in satire as a warning.
The opening segment of "Starship Troopers"
teases us with news footage of the battlefield.
Our primary protagonist, Johnny Rico, is delivered
a major blow from his adversaries before the
intro sequence fades out to a more peaceful
time, before all the mayhem on the bugs' planet,
Klendathu.
When we do return to the same scene later
on, we get a different view of this same battle
through the eyes of the soldiers, complete
with shots of the cameraman who captured the
carnage in the propaganda video we saw earlier.
While troops are unloading magazines at their
enemy, the man holding the studio camera remains
in the thick of it, documenting the bloodshed
with a steady hand.
There are numerous ways to die for the cause,
and the news cameraman goes out in a barrage
of cinematic glory.
In the "Starship Troopers" universe, Earth
in the 23rd century looks to be a lavish time
to be alive, complete with sleek technology
and bright, shiny lights.
The central plot follows Rico closely while
he reaches his decision to enlist in the military,
along with his girlfriend, Carmen, and his
best friend, Carl.
From this narrative viewpoint, the people
of Earth look like they live a cozy life.
In reality, we're seeing the lifestyle of
someone in a much higher tax bracket.
The tax plans in this world aren't explained
to us, but noticing the little details makes
it clear that Rico's parents are left with
plenty of scratch.
Rico's home is a spacious house with towering,
crystal clear windows, perched atop a mountainside.
The future looks wonderful from the viewpoint
of the wealthy.
Also, lending credence to Rico's financial
upbringing is his father's counter-argument
for enlisting.
Rather than doing his part for society, Rico's
dad would rather him go on vacation with the
family before beginning his first semester
at Harvard, neither of which are available
to those from meager means.
"Starship Troopers" does such a fantastic
job of world-building that you won't even
recognize it's happening.
In the same way that new recruits are brainwashed
into operating the cogs of war, we're subjected
to the same devices to help us realize the
sordid reality of this future.
The propaganda commercials aren't presented
as though the characters are watching them
at the moment, but as if the filmmakers are
recruiting us to learn more about the world
they created.
And laced throughout the informative commercials
are details about the vastness of this universe.
When we aren't getting battle advice, we are
presented with inter-planetary diagrams and
Earth politics.
The commercials have a slightly humorous characteristic
to them, but don't let that distract you from
seeing the bigger picture.
The small details in each quick segment expands
on the world of "Starship Troopers".
It's through these moments that we learn about
the location of the bug planet, foreshadowing
about smart bugs, Earth's war council decisions,
and more.
It's here we get to see the fascist bureaucracy
in action, and we see a world where the media
is controlled by the state.
We know creating a mental block when seeing
commercials is instinctual for most denizens
of the 21st century, but we recommend paying
attention to these ones.
As it stands today, we're approaching an Earth
population of 8 billion souls.
The exponential growth will likely lead to
gigantic numbers by the time we hit the 23rd
century.
On a planet led by a reactionary military
government like in "Starship Troopers", you'd
think officials would enact a type of control
for population growth.
Turns out there is one succinct chunk of dialogue
that informs us of the bureaucratic path towards
parenthood in this future.
It's buried in a scene that every single viewer
remembers ... and not for its informative
dialogue.
The communal shower scene in "Starship Troopers"
has so much casual nudity that it distracts
from all the expository dialogue that serves
to expand the world.
One of the soldiers begins asking his squad
mates their reason for enlisting in the military.
Among the answers are career ambitions, college
funding, and civic duty.
However, there's one especially interesting
answer from a female soldier, and it involves
a desire to have children.
That tells us that not only do you have to
register for a license in order to have kids,
but it's also not a sure thing and requires
proving yourself to society.
It's something to think about while sitting
in bumper-to-bumper traffic.
Rico is delivered a tough blow when he loses
a soldier while leading his squad through
a training exercise.
We could argue about how the man's helmet
wouldn't have done much to protect him from
a bullet to the face, but that's of little
consequence.
It's what happens after Rico signs his letter
of resignation that's interesting.
After the incident, his parents call him and
he informs them he's coming home.
The call ends with daylight slowly being snuffed
out over his mom and dad before the signal
goes dead.
The reasoning behind the signal loss is explained
so quickly that you might miss it — it comes
so fast because, evidently, news stations
have a magical ability to assemble a compelling
news package instantaneously.
As soon as Rico grabs his bag to leave after
his phone call, troops begin rushing to the
command center to take in the news of a bug
meteor that's decimated Rico's hometown of
Buenos Aires.
The time between the phone call with his parents
and the news being reported is less than a
minute.
Not only that, but in this span of time, the
war council has gathered and decided Earth
is officially going to war with the arachnids
of Klendathu.
In a population obsessed with military might,
political bureaucracy moves much quicker when
war is involved.
The reaction to the meteor strike on Buenos
Aires happens so fast that you have to wonder
if the government knew it was coming and saw
it as a desirable outcome.
There's no better way to whip your population
into a frenzy and march them into battle.
In the United Citizen Federation, becoming
a citizen is paramount.
Citizenship comes with a highly sought-after
level of respect in this society.
It opens pathways financially in the same
way that it does in current times, but the
future residents of Earth view it as the only
respectable way to become a contributing member
of society.
The most definitive statement in regards to
attaining value in this world comes from the
funeral for Dizzy, when Rico is giving his
eulogy.
The heartfelt speech is filled with emotion,
and it's also a declaration on what's required
to garner respect.
It isn't enough to be a good friend.
Being a soldier is admirable, but it's more
about the path it creates — a path towards
the ultimate goal of upgrading from simply
being a civilian to being a citizen in the
Federation.
Individuality is of little importance, and
your life is only given value when offered
up as a sacrificial lamb for the cause.
Anyone with basic understanding of human anatomy
will probably have trouble accepting the Brain
Bug's ability to absorb our knowledge by sucking
our gray matter out.
But it's a little easier to accept this detail
when you remember the presence of psychics
in "Starship Troopers".
This ability isn't featured heavily, and it's
only talked about in scenes with Neil Patrick
Harris' character, Carl.
In an earlier scene, it looks like he's trying
to test Rico's psychic abilities with a playing
card prediction game, but it's actually about
Carl flexing his own mental aptitude.
During the psychic test, Carl is trying to
send a telepathic message to Rico, giving
him the answer as to what card is being displayed.
You can tell as much by Carl's mannerisms
during the test.
The failed use of this skill plays a part
in showing us character growth in the latter
half of "Starship Troopers".
After he rescues Carmen, Rico posits that
it was Carl who mentally projected her location
to him.
Carl slyly rejects the claim, but his smirk
reveals the truth about that statement.
If the uniforms and symbols featured on the
United Citizen Federation's attire look suspiciously
Third Reich, it's because they are.
The filmmakers recognized the original "Starship
Troopers" novel as having an intriguing sci-fi
story, but they also acknowledged the book
contained a hearty dose of totalitarian rhetoric.
Paul Verhoeven aimed to have that characteristic
shine through sarcastically in the form of
satire.
The Nazi symbolism was meant to help you realize
that these characters may be heroes, but they're
heroes in a fascist society.
By the end of the film, the propaganda commercials
have done a sufficient job of putting us into
the mindset of people living on Earth in the
23rd century.
In order to pull back on the reins, Verhoeven
tried to make the nods to Nazi Germany obvious.
He stated in an interview with The Guardian:
"These soldiers were like something out of
Nazi propaganda.
I even put one in an SS uniform.
But no one noticed.
I thought Neil Patrick Harris arriving on
the set in an SS uniform might clear it up."
The small detail didn't stop some critics
from warping the director's vision, instead
viewing "Starship Troopers" as a twisted nod
to the Third Reich.
Verhoeven's motives may have been misunderstood
when the movie was released, but we see the
underlying intentions now.
And we're still unsure about whether or not
we should laugh.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.